Speaker 1: All right, let's start with a
reminder that we may need we may not need
just a reminder that the one group that seems
to continually garner the loyalty of this
kind of like neo reactionary, right,
I've continued to struggle with how we
should refer to sort of like Trumpist because
they're not conservative. They're not neo cons,
but they are reactionary and they're smitten
with dictators and brutal regimes. And the one
real loyalty that seems to be unbending and
unchanging is to authoritarians. In a new
interview on Real America's Voice, which is
rapidly becoming one of the most unhinged,
reactionary fact free media outlets out there.
Donald Trump was bemoaning the poor treatment
of Saudi Arabia by the United States, one of
the biggest violators of human rights in the
world. We've treated them poorly, says Donald
Trump in this interview. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 6: Oh yeah, you. You kind of stayed with
them through the Khashoggi thing. You said, Hey,
it's horrible, but it's not going to jeopardize
a 70 year relationship. We have now they meet
with Russia. Now they're buying, they're
selling them oil and they're taking a rubles,
trying to get rid of the petrodollar. Do you feel
that they have the KSA who stabbed us in the back?
So I think this I think they've been
treated very badly by our country.
They don't want to see the Iran nuclear
deal. That's a catastrophe and did it.
We were very, very good with Saudi Arabia and
all of them. They were buying massive amounts
of our military equipment and everything else.
Speaker 1: This really is beyond the pale. And
understand that they're all in on it. There
are even even the question from the reporter
already is framed to give a very particular
perspective. The Khashoggi thing, the Khashoggi
Khashoggi thing. It's it's horrible. But you know,
our relationship over oil and weapons. At least
they're all saying it like it is, right? I mean,
OK, yes, it was international. Premeditated murder
at the direction of the Saudi royal family in
cold blood of a member of the media planned
well in advance. People flown in with bone saws.
OK, yeah, I mean, the Khashoggi thing. But oil?
Weapons come on, guys, and it's really kind of
emblematic of how they see this, and we shouldn't
forget that it's, you know, this is not I'm not
drawing a parallel between the Khashoggi thing,
which was one guy getting killed and 9-11. These
are two different things, but it's the type of
minimization proportional minimization,
which would be like referring to 911 as
we have lots of buildings in this country. They
knocked down two, they knocked down two buildings.
But we've had this relationship for decades,
the oil and the arms, and we want the cheap
gas and. By the way, it's not not working out,
keeping it super cheap. We have to accept the
political reality that Trump and his voting bloc
their main. Either they're like chameleons where
I guess we don't hate gay people, or maybe we
do, or we're not too concerned with trans people.
But now all of a sudden we are. And maybe we we
don't want the government involved in health care
unless Trump's going to give us some even better
version of Obamacare, where the government will
be more. It's all malleable like putty. Really
crappy party, I should say. But the one thing that
doesn't change is they're just smitten with the
autocrats. Any opportunity to defend or minimize
the ills committed by autocrats and dictators and
human rights violators that they will do that has
not changed. And when you think of all of Trump's
different, unchanging loyalties, the only ones I
can find are two the autocrats and the people who
line Trump's pockets. And of course, remember that
there are Saudis that own Trump buildings, floors,
condos, whatever different, different pieces of
Trump properties. I believe the 44th floor of
Trump Tower and the like. It's not even really
America First, it's really Trump first and America
first, as ugly as is the history of America First.
It's almost a distraction where Trump says to
his base, America First. They love it, and they
don't realize that it's actually Trump first at
the end of the day. So just another one of these
examples Trump has abandoned his supporters.
Hill abandoned Republicans as soon as they say,
Well, I didn't like this one thing Trump did.
Oh, that's a rhino. He'll abandon all of them,
but he continues to be smitten with the
autocrats, and that doesn't seem to change